welcome to the dark forest checking your
pals were there for for us shameless
confession about our obsession will make
us laugh and smile so let's explore the
dark forest hello and welcome to the
dark forest it's Jackie Kashian I'm
standing while doing this intro you know
the websites Jackie Kashian calm dork
force calm the dork forest calm family
pet ancestry com recently Joe Wilson has
let go dork forest radio.com which led
everybody directly to blogtalkradio
which were the first like five years of
this show maybe six anyway math is hard
I am here to bring to you the finest
dork tins in all the world or at least
people who loves things a lot there we
go let's do the credits Patrick Brady
he's going to fix this audio mic right
bird composed and sang that song you
just heard in the beginning and he will
sing his lyrics to the Mexican Hat dance
at the end of the program Vilmos fixes
my website Jackie Kashian calm and you
can go to dork for s cobb you can go to
iTunes and download the show and
everything and dark force calm has for
free the bonus that libsyn for some
reason created to go only on the app and
then put it on the website so I just
move it over to the new website dork
force calm anyway it's a fascinating
tour story I'll tell it again at the end
yeah but here's the scoop on both dork
forest and education there is a donation
button feel free to use it if you enjoy
the program and want to donate to the
show click I and I'd love to get a
hundred dollars from everybody a year if
you have a hundred dollars ten bucks a
month I haven't made that easy you'd
have to remember or you can give it to
me all at once you can give me more than
a hundred dollars you can give me less
than a hundred dollars if you don't have
a hundred dollars feel free to just tell
people about the dork forest and how
much you like it you can also get merch
and and fly your dork flag that way
Rangers Jackie Kashian calm has two
different kinds of dork forest t-shirts
there's the black Ranger t-shirt and
there's the green the dark forest
t-shirt the brown ones being
discontinued
have some you can email me Jackie at
Jackie Kashian calm to see if I have any
left but I mostly do them at the live
shows begin live shows I do stand-up
comedy you can get the schedule their of
where I'm doing stand-up comedy you can
follow me on twitter at Jackie Kashian
and I'm constantly but it did it talking
about it so there's that there is a
chance to buy my CD zima DVD on Jackie
Kashian calm you can download the DVD
just the video of it at comedy film
nerds calm in their store just to
download ten dollars or you can buy a
hard copy from me and you can get the
cds bread circus people and horcrux all
on amazon or itunes or you can just
listen to me for free on Pandora and
Spotify I get a little bit of a kickback
speaking of a kickback you can get you
can use the amazon banner on Jackie
Kashian calm to order your stuff from
Amazon and then the dork forest gets a
tiny kick back on that and I totally
appreciate that if you order from amazon
and we all do who's going to lie about
such a thing anyway um comedy donation
Oh band camp I have premium episodes
live episodes in the last year the live
episodes have I've realized they cost me
a couple bucks so they cost everybody
who wants to listen to them a couple
bucks so if you go to the dork forest
bandcamp com you can get live episodes
with the likes of Gail Carriger and
Hollis Gillespie and Greg Proops and
Dana Gould and a bunch of other people
oh and Karen kill Gareth and guy Branum
but they're two bucks a pop and they're
fun on that bandcamp there's some other
stuff and there's a bunch of free
episodes that i culled from all the blog
talk years and that's just a free album
of like I think it's 20 episodes from
the first couple of years of the show
that I tried to clean up a little bit
the audio isn't great because no Patrick
Brady that's right anyway other than
that all things comedy calm is the
podcast umbrella of this program and so
if you're looking for more podcasts go
to all things comedy calm by God let's
get into the show hey it's Jackie
Kashian men with my living room my
living room you guys the dark forest
with Jamie Flynn how you doing Jamie I'm
so good thank you for having me
you're on the longshots podcast which I
have done more than once yet which makes
you a rarified air no I'm in rarefied
airs uh no what makes you actual rare
fighter I'm actually mm-hmm welcome to
my tiny house in the valley that I'm
very cozy it's enchanting magical little
haven we just planted tomatoes we're not
made of stone so you okay so you get the
longshot podcast which is on itunes is
that on the sideshow network as well
that's not to ask all things coming
that's not all things comedy which is
what I'm on you guys a great way to get
see other podcasts is to go to all
things comedy calm guys and maybe listen
to the longshots podcast sure and then
you have your own podcast uh the
gatekeeper yeah a keeper I just your
gatekeeper just started how many
episodes do you it I just recorded my
eighth and ninth oh there you go yeah so
and you interview Booker's Booker's
producers kind of anyone that's in
development or that say it behind the
camera yes who says yes and no and why
do they say yes to know okay hence
gatekeeper yes and you yourself a book
The Improv and very nicely booked me and
I appreciate that thank you very much
here one of the funniest people on the
planet well success uh that it's all
working out the mutual admiration
society welcome and so many I always say
anybody can be on the dork forest as
long as you do not torment me online
jesus H Christ keep it tight people
anyway um you can be done I want it's
all just scheduling and so that you've
I've wanted you to be on the show for a
long time and this is what I remember
talking about you you said and then and
then I guess we have not had a but I
think it's gonna work out I think I'm
fingers across I'm slightly panicking I
shouldn't be but i'm slightly pit I
think it's gonna be fine The Beatles you
her up here in Los Angeles yeah I grew
up in the in the valley right here in
the valley yeah how are the valley
granada hills nearby and um work did you
that were you dipped were your parents
and famous land I mean it wasn't some
sort of do they have jobs like people
yeah Beth lambs key service it's been Oh
locksmiths some Van Nuys and more
it used to be a Ventura and Woodman and
there's an ad for flans key service you
guys get out there get your keys cut
keys cut they also do commercial
mailboxes oh very nice so fight if I
were to get need a p.o box like if I
didn't want to be in the book anymore oh
I don't know about that okay but if you
literally wanted the physical mailbox oh
they sold physical they sell physical
mail boxes like apartment buildings oh
you know we have like 10 don't walls of
mailboxes that'd be kind of funny to
have one right here in van nuys mailbox
door casa yes this is a craft occasion
what so you but you grew up here and so
one of the first things you said when we
started talking about it was that you
had a beals themed bar mitzvah I did so
you're not an old man so there's no
reason for you to have been into the
Beatles as much as you were no I mean
the story of how I got into the Beatles
you know I was in six I was in fifth
grade and we had a new student at the
school and his name was Danny Cooke see
now Danny played Sam on Diff'rent
Strokes which use a little redheaded kid
oh wow possibly like the jumping the
shark moment for difference right when
they is that when they adopted a white
kid yes there we go oh the the
switcheroo the old switcheroo very nice
and so I went to this elementary school
called Chatsworth hills academy and it
wasn't an academy was just a little
private school okay and we had sooo they
have academic dreams they did excellent
my mom helped me come up with the school
slogan which actually won me a trip
there was the chatsworth christmas
parade ok i got to be on a float because
i came up with the winning slogan which
was a chest with ill economy we're
learning and fun our number 10 rhyming
couplets well played a key for him shut
up but Emma's his little school in
Chatsworth and so there were students
there that were child actors ok not a
lot but there were a handful of them and
so I grew up around some of these kids
right cuz I have to go to school
somewhere they live here and they all
live in Chatsworth
yeah okay and so this new this kid Danny
started and he was at the time on our
every kid's favorite sitcom which was
different strokes and so you know
starstruck and as were my friends
because to me he was the gateway to
start him become friends with this kid
I'm gonna be then on TV shows right and
so will introduce you to showbiz exactly
so he would be one of these beetles
cartoon t-shirts and I my first memory
of really the beatles was that this kid
who I looked up to who was super cool it
was super cool is great ahead of me he's
already partying and doing all this
stuff that my shelter that means he was
11 he was already partying yeah Wow
truly like you can't I mean like full-on
yeah well I mean I'm parties in little
Hollywood parties little tiny bowl of
latch key games um wow that's crazy
ville it was um it was crazy and I
remember my parents been a little bit
concerned me my obsession with him right
I'm sure they're like we run a key a
store if you could please keep your feet
on the ground and keep aiming for the
stars since dr. Demento but so he had
t-shirts a lauding the Beatles yeah this
bit would be like a car to the cartoon
versions of the Beatles okay and I
remember through that I was like
actually get into the Beatles right I
was I think my parents are like well we
remember the Beatles let me tell you
about the Beatles and so I went they had
some records and then I remember going
to the warehouse which was like the tape
store okay um and getting like the
Beatles odd cassette Lanka said okay the
beatles 62 to 66 was the first one okay
they're the famous red cover of their
bet the biggest heads that was a it was
a greatest hits 10 right cuz i would
have been from 1962 1967 notice it was
66 and then they have a 66 there's 67
270 which was the later years ah there
you go when did they break up um I think
70 okay and so so you listen to this
cassette tape a lot a lot mm-hmm and
became obsessed and inserted that's when
I started going through those records
and one of my best friends Michael at
the time
you know mutual obsession at the same
time I started listening to them going
through all the records and then started
I decided get a bass guitar oh we got a
regular guitar we started playing
playing songs covering the beatles cover
in the beatles all right and then that
leads to now junior high so that was
fifth and sixth grade right it started
kind of emulating someone who looked up
to but then it became a real your own
thing yeah and it was more than the
Beatles a certain point I was like
obsessed with classic rock radio mm-hmm
I listen to ke LSX 97.1 FM FM and we're
fun and learning or I don't know what
their slogan was I think it was um jams
and Sherone her I never went hot jams
and peanut butter get together and me
and everybody has a nice sandwich I why
doesn't Rock why don't rock bands do
that Iraq don't know radio stations so
you started loot so was that the cake
you of the day or something like the
local like classic rock mm-hmm and was
it was it classic rock even then cuz you
had to be a child what in the late 80s
Early 90s early 90s yeah so you're
listening to classic okay yes climb it
wasn't like 60s and 70s yeah it's so
weird analogy in the classic rock and
hearing 80 s and 90 songs right but
they're also there's still classic rock
oh they're still doing 60s and 70s I
don't know nobody's really written any
new music have they I'm abundance I'm
uncertain that's what's happening
there's a lot of cool stuff happening
was there a lot of cool is there cool
new music huh anouk is there anything
new since rap sums him up I'm a hundred
by the way and so the last real rebel I
mean there was rap and then there was
grunge and then what happened anything
happened I think if you didn't
rock-a-billy come before that was sky
before that what happened to mean Scott
is from 1362 60s okay like original sky
like from Jamaica okay because I did an
episode on sky I clearly did not
memorize it with Brandi Posey and she
she made a mixtape everyone if you're
going to send me a mixed
of songs if you want me to listen to
music I I too wish to listen to them
eight songs do not Marie Valeriano you
know Marie thank you uh gave me on USB
stick with over a hundred you two songs
you know what that has too many have
anyone to Sonja has too many songs I
don't there isn't a band in the world I
want to listen to a hundred of their
songs but um so what do you think what
do I think about new music oh i think
there's a butt ton of great stuff and
you just have to kind of five minutes
there's there's so many ways to get it
now that it's so oversaturated but you
know you find your your blog or your you
know pitchfork is you know it's very
hipstery but pitchfork com or something
is it a it's like a music review website
for this is they have tons of content
but every year at the end of the year
they put out their top hundred albums
top you know hundred singles and but is
it all guitar rock or no it's very
eclectic it's a rock and hip hop and
dance music and electronic and write is
already but it's already new music like
he's anyone taking a trumpet and playing
it through the other end and then
creating something that I didn't know
about or are we still working with the
same instruments and the same beat i
would say electronic is the most
experimental but she's using you know
I'm technology to create music has
opened new pathways and okay you know
I've always said new pathways new
pathways and is there is there an
electronic like it in electronica and
this is not your dorkdom but now we're
weaving off into it I Laraine Newman did
an EDM episode and she loves electronic
dance music which is what EDM stands for
I now know that and but she do you think
that there's electronic covers of like
the beatles and the rolling stones and
Jethro Tull or whatever else a lot of
electronic tone electronic today that's
the flute band right that's the band
without a whimsical uh very progressive
rock right that's prog rock right Jethro
Tull yeah okay yeah yes oh and yes I
remember I remember
these words these are names of bands and
in Japan I think what you need to know
about me about the 70s I was listened to
a lot of Harry Chapin and Billy Joel
sure boohoo lot of sobbing sobbing
briefly into a cracked mirror yeah in
the hopes to regroup but what so let's
see well actually made a good way to
bring it back is it's probably 10 or 12
or 15 years old now maybe 10 years but
um the classic mashup of jay-z's um
Black Album ok and the Beatles White
Album by danger mouse he basically
mashed these two records together and
called the grey album okay so that would
be a perfect example that is a perfect
example of weight so did dane is danger
mouse a hip-hop singer he's a producer
there was a producer and and and does he
talk into the mic at all does he I'm
sure there's examples of him doing that
I'm not super savvy with it but how did
he how'd it what is the grey album is
the grey album does it sound more
Beatles or does it sound more basically
taking yesterday is it taking like I
don't think yesterday's on it ok was on
the white album what what songs that I
that I might know I JK Shin who know
nothing I only them what album what uh
rocky raccoon happiness is a warm gun
sure um and then he's on my dear okay
revolution okay the both versions no
doubt both versions sure revolution
number nine is the avant-garde 13-minute
or whatever it is right somebody
actually play it backwards it says turn
me on dead man does it yeah turn me on
Dedmon how do you play something
backwards if they've a turntable knees
oh and then you actually physically
which again gets us back to hip-hop oh
right there's art of scratching and the
art of I'm sure I'm familiar that's not
anything like what it sounds like but
again i'm available to uh to drop your
beats for you you guys out there but
what so so you're playing when you're
ten and eleven years old you start
playing the beatles
and then what is a Beatles / Mitzvah so
the pto's Bar Mitzvah was it's more so
the reception I mean the Pokemon itself
or the permits was all in Hebrew yeah
that's just chanting Hebrew right a lot
of memorization talk to me briefly about
this memorization did you have to
memorize or could you read it you have
to memorize but you had to memorize the
chance you to remember reading on
occasion or okay but you're chanting it
so you have to remember like where are
you gonna like where the breath marks
are and Libya exactly and uh wait that's
a different so that but so okay so sort
of like a any sort of birthday party but
this is your 13th birthday party so then
yeah and especially I think in the San
Fernando Valley a hotbed for us Jews a
hotbed of Judaism lavallee but I think
it's as much and I don't think my
parents are as guilty of this I mean in
this day and age you know bits I think
everyone's trying to help do each other
yeah there seems to be that I have some
very impressive Armenian neighbors who
are constantly buying bouncy houses for
their kids and I'm like just calm down
give him a piece of string they'll be
happy but so there there was some out
doing and so I mean it was only got the
committal sucked into it it just d
matically you want to put on a great
party and sure Pressey relatives and
your friends and make sure everybody has
a good time and make sure nobody says
they didn't do it right or they were
cheap or they didn't rise to the
occasion or whatever so they hired the
debate is that where the Beatles reunion
happened was it at your Bar Mitzvah it
was yeah yeah that was the that was the
huge reveal oh how crazy would that be
that would be the biggest thing is that
if they could somehow talk this is kinda
like one of my clothes my parents close
friends at their daughter's wedding the
wolf was that famous guys name could be
anyone right now we live here he's on
Melvin judges on the show Simon the
voice okay no and then in a band that's
very big okay one direction
mr. naming random things they're big
enough the way you should know this guy
and I absolutely should know who the
dave matthews band no okay this is a fun
game the song moves like jagger okay who
sings that I don't know but someone
right now is yelling at their ipod very
though there you go that guy that guy
and his band surprised everyone and
played their wedding oh wow and I think
it was for a bigger project but reaching
been someone's Bar Mitzvah yeah it was a
wedding but anyways yeah yeah so the
reception was at the ventura club which
is unbent era it's now a baja fresh or
Billy or something sure but then it was
a reception hall very nice sure one of
those one of there are a million of them
here in the valley quite honestly you
can hire any sort of a building and the
hook yep poquito mas it's been there's a
there's a paquita for this josh levine
adam levine animal v all right that's
the guy that sings in the bend oh good
right now people know note to self you
guys so what orrible that's good and
then they showed up but on your sister
would their paper plates that had
pictures of the beatles on it what does
abeel seemed so the centerpieces had
little 45 records oh then you know we
printed out little stickers to go to
them so people were sitting at the she
loves you table in the name d.i.b road
table and okay Oh like that yeah so it
was like that okay and then they played
a lot of beetles probably for there were
something Beatles and I recently
uncovered the the video from the event
okay and so there's some beatles songs
there's a music booth it's kind of cool
thing they got they got this booth so
that you could go and pick a song and
you know friends would do basically
karaoke oh that I I love that idea you
get a cassette at the end oh my god
where's that machine I think it's way
outdated I know because nobody has a
cassette player anymore but when what
you know what I've actually seen comics
who put out their albums on cassettes
cuz everybody's doing it on vinyl
because they're super cool well I went
and saw Elvis Costello last night and a
young band two sisters uh kind of
country kind of rockabilly kind of Janis
Joplin e is
they're called larkin poe okay and
they're on Conan I guess tonight not
tonight because this will come out in
two weeks but they they had their album
as a CD or vinyl and i bought the CD we
don't we have some albums sitting around
this house we don't have a turntable I
don't gave away my clothes and play
quite some time ago and the clothes
remember the clothes I don't know if you
ever remembered the clothes and play
yeah it was a it was a record player for
kids oh and it opens when it opens it
would stop automatically so that you
could not break the album it was for
kids it would only play the album when
the top was all the way down but I don't
know if it would fit a full em I think
it just fit 45 because it was for kids
and kids are stupid and they can't
handle it I Randall the truth and so so
62 too what's your favorite Beatles song
who's your favorite Beatle those are
great questions yeah do you have a
favorite Beatle I well you know there's
a war I understand Yoko might have
broken up than the team or something I
was always John guy you were a John guy
all the time but then George kind of
became the cool and the like okay and
then recently um George Harrison yeah
okay the underdog yeah that is an
underdog I think he's an underrated
guitarist okay although Vienna so he had
a couple of albums right didn't have an
acclaimed solo album a few okay more
than one yeah good for him yeah great
for him yeah and he was a traveling
Wilbury do you remember them oh I do
remember them briefly who's him Bob
Dylan Tom Petty Jeff Lynne and I think
wrinkles Jesus and Roy Orbison what
powerhouse that's a crazy that's a crazy
mashup of and that all came out right at
the time that I was upset select the
late 80s Early 90s okay wow so so but
why did you like John Lennon did you
like him cuz he was super good the cool
guy or I don't know I was like ten the
most um this is there's definitely a
distinction especially in later years
between a John song and appalled song
and Paul maybe was on the more poppy
side John was the more introspective
what
to John song that's introspective I mean
so I mean do you think of imagine okay
but that's solo isn't it what is there
is area beyond the white happen that's a
that's a Beatles one Julia I don't even
know that song offhand you don't have
you heard it I bet I would but cuz and
what did Paul right um I mean a million
other songs I mean it's overwhelming
when you think about that their catalog
but in in the Beatles did he was there a
poppy one that Paul wrote this up and
this you know if you'd asked me 20 years
ago you were those specifics like was
much more entrenched in that right well
and then and I know that Paul went on to
do wings and then a sort of solo career
that has spanned lo these many years and
and I know that here's what I know about
John Lennon I i watch all of the Dick
Cavett that I can and there is a dick
cavett interview with John Lennon where
they're just sitting there no doubt
drinking something alcoholic and chain
smoking and John is talking about i
think it was in like 72 or 73 was after
they broke up and Dick Cavett asks him
about Yoko and the stuff about them
break her breaking up the band and I'm
paraphrasing but I prefer i remember
correctly john said you know people
always say that but look at the good
work that paul is done if that's true
you should thank Yoko if you really
think that which that's not what
happened but but you should be psyched
because he's gotten to expand his
creativity into these amazing places
that it would not have been possible if
we had stayed in the Beatles so and
that's a good point i mean the craziest
thing about the Beatles is that I mean
they were together for four years before
and you know put in those 10,000 hours
of your about overlaying and clubs in
the cavern club and then in Hamburg
Germany they played you know five shows
a night for three years or whatever it
was Wow so they had already been working
together but they came to America in 64
right and by they were broken up by 70
it was like this six years
of the most crazy evolution and of
course in the early and mid 20s at this
point they're all under 30 i think when
they when they broke up and so you think
about that year of their life and you
know and creatively artistically just
the sheer volume that they put out in
that time of course they were gonna get
to the point where their ideas and
they're gonna start butting heads so i
think yoko is an easy scapegoat right
this is right the podcast where Jamie
comes out in defense of Yoko Ono exactly
I don't want to listen to Yoko Ono sing
anything personally just because it's
not for me I'm sure she's a it's amazing
to those who enjoy her work but but I'm
not it's not dad it it's not catchy the
guy can't sing along it's hard for me so
but but i do remember liking both John
Lennon and Paul McCartney separately and
not having any idea what Georgia Ringo
was doing and I think my brother
explained it to me that they were living
on residuals they were to say it was
royalties and they were buying land who
knows what they were doing no I mean the
George had a flourishing career of his
own but had tons of flowers oh yeah and
I want to be have a flower shop for some
reason George what is is Ringo still
alive still alive keep it out but he
have a bunch of solo albums um he's a
drummer though right settle drummer hey
how do you how do you I suppose Phil
Collins isn't he a drama he is it
drummers well he said he had some solo
albums you just hire people to play
around you I guess is that what you do
yeah all right but is Ringo sang songs
the iMini usually had one to two songs
on the White Album I think he had two or
three songs that were zone mm-hmm and I
mean the White Album especially the
Beatles at that point we're so in their
own worlds like it really is every song
so dis Britain it's you can tell like
you know who wrote it and who's all Wow
and that's part of the magic stew is
them at that point you'd think that they
were already gonna be broken up but and
this one makes Abbey Road which was out
last time they recorded all the more
magical because it's like they it was
let's give it one more shot guys okay
and to me that's you know arguably one
of the best albums especially the side
to of abbey road okay look there's a
medley and it's just like all their
these elements that were they were
really working together again they were
like we're gonna work together we're
gonna do it like sort of their earlier
stuff and then did they and and the
white album did it feel like sort of
like everybody was like fine we'll just
break up the tracks do whatever you want
kind of thing yeah I mean you know some
tracks then every every track every
Beatle strike has a story behind it and
you know some tracks were oh I suppose
people are obsessed with the Beatles
they're like how did this one song
happen if you're gonna Wikipedia know
like yeah every song has like some sort
of crazy backstory I'm trying it uh I
have um I have a double a CD the red
cover it's the number one it's all their
number one hits and um and I'm trying to
I can't even think of I mean I know that
I know the Beatles I mean there's not
those there's no way there's no it'd be
like not knowing something like me not
knowing who the quarterback for the
Packers is I don't know I do just
through osmosis like I also i have
access to a lot of things jesus said
because of church but there there's no
way that I don't I let me be the first
to compare the Beatles to Jesus oh wait
anyway I'm here all week yes ah that's
funny anyway but but but yeah I mean I
know that I know the songs but is there
what's what's a good story about one of
those songs a good story I mean like a
good song that what's one of your
favorite songs of theirs that as a good
story attached to it I can't even think
of a song which is ridiculous it's a
great question it's a great question
this is what I do I say there I think of
questions that's what I like but Abbey
Road so Abbey Road what songs are on
Abbey Road um seine king I want you oh
that you would
there's something in the way she moves
oh yeah um Maxwell's silver hammer all
right what's the story of Maxwell's
silver hammer they just stoned out of
their damn minds I think that might be
this way for a lot of them yeah why not
if if the pot was free and it often is I
just talked to Doug Benson so when it's
constantly handing that guy a joint and
um you never give me your money it's um
what's that is that a song song okay um
oh um it's the most you know the song
come together okay come together um
another song but people know that you
you know come together yeah do you have
a story about that story thing ya know I
don't I'm sorry Malcolm together I have
the stories about me listen to them more
so than i have about let's hear that i
want to hear that then what's your
favorite um story of you listen to the
beatles it's a saturday afternoon ok
there we go i'm tired i'm beat no energy
then I throw on helter skelter and all
of a sudden yep this little 14 year old
wants to go change the people I love man
oh there you go cuz helter skelter was
about murder it was about Charles Manson
ok a bit but based on the book about the
Menton killers ok so do you just get
stoned and listen to a lot of beatles is
that what's happening as a kid no I
started smoking pot until after my
obsession okay but there's beetle fest
like to have a beetle fest sure beetle
fest would I don't know if it still
happens but it was a beetle festival mmm
I took place at the westin bonaventure
hotel downtown LA okay and I would go
every year and you know you know see of
booths of you know people selling merch
yeah I would get you know hundreds of
posters every year and it's selling
beetle dolls old records anything you
can imagine yeah I have like special
drop in guests like now in the this
conference room Alf picknelly was their
chauffeur from 62 to 65 Sharon's stories
about uh em and then they had the battle
of the bands and in 1990
d I believe in 91 I got my buddies
together and we submit our band and we
were we got in oh wow and so the band's
they're all like their 20s 30s all old
people right not old now but right but
they were all established musicians and
these were cover bands yeah so for this
for be told fastball the band's you go
panida Beatles songs right and so we
rehearsed got her songs down and then we
got up there and just by nature of us
not looking like everyone else yeah and
yeah interest of the stage and these for
14 year old kids my daughter had my
growth spurt so I was like at one point
in my life was actually the tallest fair
enough um but at the time to the guys in
the band Gabe and Mike you know we're
tiny okay I look like they're like nine
years old and gave the singer and um Lee
qatar player he had a this amazing voice
and so we do um oh darling which is also
on Abbey Road okay and it's Paula
singing and it's like he belts it out
and so in Gabe just you know his his
little lungs just went out there and he
kicked ass and yeah through people
through a loop they're going crazy yeah
I might have been the best moment of my
life and did they did you guys win or
did you come and do sir there's by 20
bands and then there was a runoff
between three of us we were going to top
three Wow then it came down to to the
top two but then well we ultimately lost
to glass onion glass onion was the name
of the cover band that song from White
Album and does does Gabe's still sing
Gabe has an amazing career yeah as a
musician he's in a band called the punch
brothers now oh there you go there a
bluegrass band he was always a bluegrass
he grew up in a bluegrass man with his
family oh my god that's hilarious and
Michael who's guitar player and one of
my best friends yeah I'm still plays
Johansson ok so those guys kept with the
music and kept doing it and what about
the other was their fourth there was a
fourth who was the fourth his name was
Anthony and he went on to become a
banker or sun ovals his dad yeah um his
him his dad was named Dawn was ok don
was from was not was
yes weird and why do I know that coming
out of I don't there's you went do you
no matter their big song no no the
dinosaur sure I know the name of that
song so you went and you were in junior
I with don was a son and then you were
in a band with his son his well he was
Gabe's cousin I believe okay and so don
was at the time I don't know if he still
does lived in this amazing house up in
coldwater canyon okay and so when were
forming the band is like a we should get
my cousin in it and his dad's a famous
producer in bubble yeah so we would go
up into this kind of mansion a place
sure cold water that's where the
mansions are being kept in Los Angeles
right could crazyville and so i'll never
forget one of the rehearsals we went to
UM Don walked in we had his little you
know studio area right and he was like
sorry I took so long i was on the phone
with Mick Jagger oh my god any gold
records everywhere he like produced
major Elam's ok so he he was in that
band the very famous band was not was
but he was also a producer like I think
he became more famous as a producer did
me Oh much more yeah good was not was
was was great and everybody it was there
was cult sort of following of it some
small success or bigger than 0 initially
like to know where what was the what was
was that was it sad I don't know I all I
remember is a I'm calling you from jail
and I think the only was not was song I
ever knew knew was from the movie pump
up the volume which is with Christian
Slater maybe and it was my introduction
to Leonard Cohen my introduction to was
that was and my introduction to guys
jerking off and making that noise so I a
lot of things were learned and then i
bought the soundtrack to that up i mean
that's that's my that's the way i buy
music by the way i'll listen to uh that
pen is gone i drop that pen that'll
happen Oh extra pen coming yeah I just I
by soundtracks more than anything else
I'm like oh I wonder who those fans are
somethin weird if I music yeah and then
i might buy the album from
one of the songs that's run on that and
so is there so that's kind of
fascinating that you got to meet that
guy yeah if I forget about that but um
he played bass too so it would teach me
some stuff oh wow and of course you know
as soon as I got to 10th grade I was
done playing bass for a while but what
brought you away from it when we lured
you into the hand like a like a baby
bird being safe to be like the need for
popularity than yeah today's any girls
and and stop practicing the base I
really gave up I mean I've no regrets no
regrets he can't regret I really did you
know move away from music and I was
obsessed with musical theatre know
performing all those things that I at
that point decided were dorky or oh
right you owe you rejected them as kind
of dorky yeah and I became obsessed with
hip-hop was a genuine obsession but it
was also made trying at that point in my
life too I think that that leads us to
some you're just like you're like well
cool people I know like that so I'm
gonna look into it and then there's a
reason they like it because it's kind of
cool you know I mean a friend of mining
cut in 1989 loved boogie down
productions and so that's how i got into
hip-hop and but she also liked XTC um
which I only recently realized stands
for ecstasy oh uh yeah I may not do a
lot of drugs anyway and never have uh
luckily never got into drugs but the the
I think I never cared for XTC they were
not for me but I liked black flag I like
some of the punk stuff which by the way
my punk knowledge comes entirely from
the movie repo man with Emilio Estevez
yes very all the hits are coming out
today all the hits everything I we well
the thing is is every time there's an
episode about music it is a spiral of me
just grasping at straws of what I might
know about music someone that does no
music doesn't just drop boogie down
production well as I think it's been
established previously of the dork
forest I own one album of everything so
and then I don't know anything else
about you know more than most so well
I think though there is a young man one
of these young when these young turks a
comedy he wants to come on talk about
music and I am of course terrified just
the idea of it because I don't know what
it's it's hard to it's hard to lead what
other was so what happened with the
Beatles any other good Beatles stuff you
want to tell her or do you want to move
on to other things no I mean I think I
have a couple other stories I've
definitely told on long shot but I mean
one of the most classic stories of my
life was um when I was I think 14 so
right around this time yeah I get home
after school one day and the phone rings
and I pick it up and on the other line
and the line is a fellow claiming that
their Ringo Starr what is like hellos
Jamie am I actually I'm not gonna even
try to do the excellent right right
probably blow alone whoa wait a minute
wow that's why I did there's a reason I
don't get work how'd you have all my
albums yeah that's the best I can do i
got'em and of course I'm like ah
business yeah and you know start listing
throw events is this mike mike come on
now this is Ringo Starr engine and you
know why would he be calling me and then
finally after a minute of this of them
just being like thank you for this now
my own again um I hear my dad pick up
another phone it's a right it's like
jamie is this is Ringo don't [ __ ] this
up right in my memory he said don't [ __ ]
this up I don't think would actually
said that right but um the story was
Ringo was shooting a movie mm-hmm in the
valley somewhere sure and him in a
producer they were doing a scene where
someone had to I think break into a safe
oh so there were key needs they went to
get some consulting on how to shoot the
scene to make it look like they're
breaking the safe or whatever yeah and
God bless my dad it's I'd want to close
things ever is that he had the balls
right and that like in the moment kind
of thought you knew loves the Beatles my
son Ringo Starr I will help you and yet
you must call my son and talk to him
yeah so you got to talk to him for a
couple of minutes or a minute well as
soon as my dad got off and it was like
this is Ringo I started screaming like I
was at the edge Sullivan Show in 1964
right I would like screaming like a like
a 16 year old girl watching The Beatles
right and just running around the house
and I don't know I think everything else
after that I forgot right but that's
that's um that is amazing I mean it's
one of those things where you definitely
there's no have you met any other
Beatles and well dad that's in the last
year um Tom carne came to the improv
three times what how come me you know
who was there the night I was there um
Alex Trebek I remember that so I had a
picture with him I didn't get a picture
of him I thought I don't usually ask for
pictures with people but when's the next
time I'm gonna get to meet I mean Alex
Trebek is a hundred and seven years old
but thank you to me is like it's he's up
there as far as I eat a cool dude I mean
the fact that he came was very and he
was he was very sweet it was sort of um
what's his name um penny Marshall's
brother Gary that's what I like to think
of a mass I like to think of ms penny
Marshall's brother Gary Marshall once
said to me he said you're very talented
and I wish I'd had that on tape a pillow
and I wish he was standing next to me
and had a photograph with me so when I
met Alex Trebek I thought they said you
don't get to meet these guys that often
so get a picture did you get a picture
with Paul McCartney I did oh that's
awesome hey well so he came in the first
time he came in I was out of the town I
was up in big bear for a week and did
you cry and I never go out of town
mm-hmm I mean ever are not working I'm
always there right and it was just this
random night and I remember I've got an
Instagram i'm scrolling through and then
see this picture of beauty paula and
prob like oh my god not tonight not
tonight tonight and it was tonight it so
I miss him the first time yeah about two
weeks later that was another night and I
didn't hear about it to the next day you
missed him again I went home early and I
lived three blocks from the improv right
and so I that next day I went everyone
on staff I was like [ __ ] Paul
McCartney comes back and I'm not one to
raise my voice right but um I was like
it so please text me you call me send up
a flare for the bluff of the baby Jesus
get Jamie flan
to the improv to see in person right
Paul McCartney and so third time's the
charm yeah came to pass I went home
early this night and then of course my
phone sort of blowing up yeah everyone's
like come on back he's here so I rates
back sure enough he was there and had a
moment you know I snuck into a picture
with him and yeah um had a moment where
I went up to him he was sitting in the
back and so he was on on tour this last
year and he was I think rehearsing for
the tour somewhere over here in the
valley okay and just like the improv
felt safe there and thought he'd go see
some comedy yeah anybody we just get
this phone call I guess I each time he
would call up and say hey this bomb
carne or maybe was one of those hey
idler hopefully hopefully he has someone
to make that call for him he doesn't
have to hit you like the president
calling and ordering flowers in the
American president anyway so so he just
rolled up and noticed him and one other
guy but I went up to on the back in to
introduce myself and you know tell him
on the Booker and it's a pleasure and an
honor to have him here right cuz it's
always so embarrassing to try to
introduce yourself to someone famous you
kind of want to justify why you think
it's okay that you're like well this is
my place of work this is what I do but
I'm not just some dude coming up to you
and interrupting you know yeah yeah and
it's a weird it's a weird thing but i
love that that you feel that i wasn't
going to and then one of our sound guy
that night was just like Jamie this is
your only chance this is your only
chance you really I mean that's why I
thought and Alex Trebek is no Paul
McCartney I mean he's no john kennedy
but it was voucher bekas arguably the
beetle of television gameshows sure i
mean if i could have met richard Dawson
it would have been very exciting Tim
Dawson and trip Pat Sajak the richard
Dawson always felt like he was the
Cayenne elbows squeeze or a kind of guy
we're a bit alike a little petty very
many yeah I was like oh I don't know
that I wanted to meet richard Dawson
quite so much he's like the peak best of
her is Pete best the the non beetle yes
the beetle well there's two there's Pete
best and Stu Sutcliffe okay Pete best i
think was actually fired okay he was the
drummer and that they felt just wasn't a
fit writer manager was like we need to
go in a different direction right don't
quote me on that story I I proving that
i know a lot about the Beatles of not
stories right not enough stories and I
just remembered who I had on who talked
about the Beatles one time and I think
it was Pat Francis who is Jimmy Pardo's
a really good friend to juvy photos
comic and very funny guy but he collects
autographs and he had some sort of crazy
Pete best story that I didn't know
enough about to really you guys there's
other what I'm saying is that if you
want more go to your local library or
Google the words the dork forest and the
Beatles and you'll get many different
tales of what can happen I'm with at jb
flying by the way it's j am IE Fla em em
em like Manson can tell you well that is
weird that i went with an n like Nancy
it's a am like man or not the first
Eddie Pepitone oi did podcast for four
years right years in a row and always
thought it was flan yeah I always
thought it was flan I like and then I
thought is a pronounced flaunt but it
isn't cuz its flam twit with an Amber
this so it's at j beef lamb and
gatekeeper is of the cool new pod that
people keep telling me is cool and new
oh cool and long chat pod is old old old
you guys have been do that forever but
it is super fun cuz it's with you have
to come back amber tozer and amber Kenny
Kenny what yeah tipping amber son of a
damn Amber's my thing you know that I
had up lunch yesterday with Amber tozer
and I called her amber Preston it's not
so um there's some Amber's out there you
guys people have been named after the
beautiful jewelry that is amber theyyam
it's a rod resin I thought it was um is
it would raisin don't call me nothing
else it is we did it's just this is a
pack of lies this dark forest is
sponsored by the devil we don't yeah we
don't have all the information you guys
feel free to google everything and then
someone will email me and tell me what
amber is off hand all I know is that my
gran
mother Armenian old Armenian ladies have
a lot of amber jewelry that they pass on
to their kids and it's always too big to
wear so I have a lot of large amber
pieces that I don't I've tried to do
various things with all I've done is
ended up destroying the necklace my
grandmother gave me so worst case
scenario you have something upon should
things there does seem to be a lot of
amber in pawn shops have you noticed
that apparently I don't know you spent a
lot of time in point I know as a nice
picture what amber in that it's you know
I'm doing a new podcast with Laurie
Kilmartin I and nobody has more more
snark to say about the Armenian people
my people then Laurie Kilmartin and it
is a joy to behold though cheat the
other night she made some crack about
how she she likes Armenians sometimes
but she just doesn't like chandeliers so
it's very hard to hang out with them and
always toting around on chandelier
always total run along and so I think I
should direct reference up more amber
maybe she could make a loose amber
reference because there are a lot there
is a lot of amber in the Armenian
community so you have to build up those
stereotypes mm-hmm sometimes you can
create him out of nothing but a whole
cloth you're like you know the I don't
know if you remember an old Dana Gould
joke about the Belgians anyway this is
dad hated people but he he it was always
somebody weird that nobody hated and so
he would always make some crack about
the Belgians anyway other Dana Gould
jokes that I also enjoy a great deal
you're you're reading from your Google
Notebook my gold notebook I got a
notebook about the great jokes of Dana
Gould what what else you got another
butyl yeah you got anything Vito's I
told the Ringo Starr story we got the
Paul McCartney right up and in to the
club and don't have a good George story
uh who's left John John died where were
you when John died reborn that's four
years old were four years old her a baby
your child so you didn't do it I didn't
do it or if I did I was you were
precocious as all hell man what were you
doing in New York I don't know wandering
around I think was the lower west side
wasn't it
forget where he lived it was one of the
west sides lower upper it was mind of an
upper the Dakotas I'll go yeah yeah
that's right drop in knowledge that's
you you got some info it's a I'd like I
don't know I i also have a double l to
double CD set of the best of wings
history and hits is what it's called one
CD is the hits and that's all I think
the number one songs that wings did and
there's like 30 of them there's so many
nobody's more prolific I don't think
than Paul McCartney and then the history
ones are sort of these b-sides that I've
also heard many of them I mean it's
weird how many just how many songs he's
written all of them i mean really is
insane how much they put out and how
important they are it's weird now i
think it's a kind of a cool thing for
people to say that their beetle hater or
that you're it's always the beatles
first the rolling stones and I've never
understood that argument yeah I think
cuz they were both 25 and everybody
wanted to sleep with all of them and
they're like my like you got longer hair
well now they have long hair they're
just want to get laid so I don't
understand either I mean though the
Rolling Stone it was more it was their
their music was harder rock if I
remember correctly right yeah just more
I mean it was harder rock but it just
did they're both very different by me
they're still experimental they're still
you know at the same time you're that's
what's so cool about the Beatles and the
stones and I think a lot of music that
generations really just reflecting
because it was so much happening in the
world at that point and the US you know
that shift with them yeah the war
happening and just the psychedelic and
the love movement and write all the new
drugs and then there was a bunch of and
there was a new war and it was it was a
new protest thing and a lot of very
well-to-do people raising children who
didn't who had a lot of free time my
father always said about wealthy wealthy
nations that's why there's revolution
that's why I in not revolution by the
way the name of my beatles cover band oh
is that the name of your Beatles cover
band when you were 14 interesting that's
and how did you dress for this event do
you guys were like hippie clothes or it
was did you try to go late Beatles or
early Beatles went early Beatles oh so
my lasers yeah and then the skinny tie
we didn't do the tie for some reason
right well you got a fine ties and when
you're 14 and you're just putting
together essentially what our costumes
you do what you can I was more of a mop
top II actually it's funny I found the
submission that I sent into beetle fest
for our band mhm and then on the back
and I was very brash I should have
brought that with me Yeah right on there
but I'm it was like my name is Jamie
flam I'm a male and it's funny all the
letters I wrote back then always and I
would write letters and it's funny I
actually have drafts of red letters I
wrote to the tom petty and our Baker's
fan club okay too I would write to Kayla
sex so I talked about right every year
on New Year's they would like to play
the top 500 classic rock songs of all
time and I don't know that I even had
the wherewithal to do this but I would
call the station and ask them to mail me
that the list and so every year they
would send they would mail me this you
know packet of like you know 25 pages
just listening listing the 5 top 500
songs like yeah they don't break out
highlighters mm-hmm this is really weird
and just know this is exam in at 50 this
is when people this is when the dork
tomb actually happened right go I would
highlight so the Beatles would be the
pink highlighter and the Rolling Stones
be the yellow led zeppelin would be
green and start going down and then
tallying like all right the beatles had
45 songs than top 500 and the Rolling
Stones and then yeah just seemed like
who had the most songs who had the most
songs than top hundred it was pretty
weird right right it was it was you
cared you want it you wanted the Beatles
to win sure why not and then did you
take that list and and listen to any
other new music because of it oh yeah
whatever um you know opening me up to
you know pop stuff and like sticks and
like the Emerson Lake & Palmer errs and
and yes and which are all ten years
before you were you know and it any
interest in listening to anything that's
it is good i mean in like Yardbirds and
obviously Pink Floyd was always right
Pink Floyd and led zeppelin i did a pink
floyd episode recently and it was
interesting I don't know I don't know
wearing about the Pink Floyd I mustn't
do a little bit afterwards and it was it
was I've now listen to some sky I've
listened to something Floyd and I have
listened um and I have a pretty wide
spectrum sure oh it turns out all this
it anything it'll be fine hey Floyd
great yeah you're really good sure here
first folks you heard of here yeah take
a stand take a stand the Pink Floyd was
pretty good I think somebody wanted me
to listen to a lot of led zeppelin at
some point her right and hide yeah yeah
all right I mean I never I don't think I
was ever high enough to really get into
that sort of acid prog rock kind of
stuff where it was all loosey-goosey and
I'm like because I like a story I don't
know if you guys remember the wreck of
the edmund fitzgerald but it was Gordon
Lightfoot ok Gordon Lightfoot wrote one
song and it was best um summed up with
the wreck of the edmund fitzgerald which
is a story about a boat that sinks in
either Lake Michigan early Xperia I
can't remember it was probably Michigan
that's where I grew up right right
against like Michigan price and but I
have a nice story and I like I do that's
one of the reasons I liked hip-hop cuz I
like country music because it had a nice
story so sometimes the Beatles would
lose me when it got all uh existential
or or just trippy you know I was like ah
I see that here I don't see what you're
doing but I see what you're doing I
don't think I wanted there to be a narc
I wanted there to be a tale so a day in
the life that might be the best beatles
song by the way oh yeah you know sir no
no I'll look that one up I had the knees
today oh boy that's one of their best
ones I do know that she definitely yeah
yeah I know that song a day and wife
yeah um I'm trying think about a good
store I mean rocky raccoon on right I
used to love I used to love rocky
raccoon that's just straight up that's
straight all right here's a story about
a
family there's another song on the whelm
called them bungalow bill yeah I like Oh
way like that's one dude fun little
jewelry yeah sure yeah and that's and
that is the other thing too is I do i do
get sucked into sort of a pie like a
poppy beat which is why I I guess I
always tended to lean more toward Paul
McCartney emotionally lemon was more
interesting just because he was brewed
ear you know he was more brooding and
unless he was more interesting seeming
than paul mccartney but remember pipes
of peace I'm I do yeah that's like a
deep cut that is pipes of peace I only
remembered because early years of MTV in
my college co-op I lived in a coop that
had we at MTV and I remember I would
just stop everything when that when was
that I remember that being like a lot of
the music video it was an amazing it was
a pretty good hit and then it was also a
music video and the music video was set
during World War one oh I dunno exactly
we're talking yeah you've seen it where
the insurance on the English exchange
letters on that Christmas night and then
a little fun history fact is they made
that illegal in the Army afterwards they
were like even though it's a ceasefire
please do not humanize your enemies
because you're gonna have to kill him
tomorrow so honey yeah that album I had
that album and I'll listen to it a lot
but there's a song that he does with
Michael Jackson ebony and ivory no II
it's called the man I mean he did the
famous song is um everything I've read
Stevie Wonder oh that's right oh and all
i remember is the drama that they wasn't
recorded in the same country they
recorded it in different Oh studios and
I think Stevie Wonder was a stevie
wonder stevie wonder was in like the
Bahamas or something and the Caribbean
somewhere on vacation and then he went
into the studio and recorded his part
and Paul McCartney it was Paul McCartney
recorded it in London and there was some
sort of drama about how it's not going
to heal racism if they can't even be in
the same room together they're like well
because because they don't want to yeah
it's completely absurd anyway but you
were gonna want the others almost say
say say okay
a big Michael Jackson Paul McCartney
there's some called the man and i'm
pretty sure it's about Jesus okay um
it's not about the man you know the man
is keeping you down it plays the game of
life so well ooh there's such a man oh
my god I don't know that song I don't
think anyone does I think it's in it's
so catchy yeah I think it was maybe a
little too religious I mean I don't say
Jesus and maybe it's not okay but I'm
just assuming it is but then cuz it's
certainly not talking about I don't know
um some sort of financial like the man
man it isn't the womb okay I think
they're talking about a magical man okay
Oh a magical man he plays data Jesus I
think we know that that is Jesus he is
very magical but I will look up the man
yea tall McCartney listen to I think
you're gonna like it okay very catchy
meet um yeah and then Beatles I mean
another cool thing and part of the the
thrill of becoming a Beatle fan well as
you know i got that 62 to 66 album and
you start to get into them and like all
these are really poppy and fun and then
when I got the 6770 you see this
dramatic change and you start to hear
about the stories and I think that's why
anyone gets in anything especially
musicians and obviously Elvis Presley
and it's like the crazy story behind the
story of everything and but finding out
about the Paula's dead thing oh right
you know what that it was a rumor that
Paul McCartney died yes and so as soon
as you hear that he started going to
digging through the albums and looking
for the clues and back then now it's on
youtube if you look it up i forgot it's
like a famous i think radio host did an
episode of his show I in the 80s called
Paul is dead and Nia produced like this
hour long is Paul dead through the next
hour we'll be looking good things to see
if he had actually died they tell the
whole story and it's insane how
obviously he didn't die right he died he
was on he was not dead but all the crazy
stories and clues we thought he was dead
this rumor got out that he died in a car
crash in the 60s right before Sergeant
Pepper came out okay and so starting
with sergeant pepper I think the rumor
came out like by 68 or 69 because people
started looking back and obviously when
you're looking for clues for something
you're gonna make a clue out of
everything okay and but there's all
these amazing little things on the
album's and in the songs and the lyrics
and where I mean subject said that he
might have been replaced by a clone or
something or apparently according to the
Lord the guide one a Paul McCartney said
sing-along contest and they went missing
ah I put him in and then lovely ritas
about the woman that picked him up and
they died in the car together and wow
that's so serious fan fiction about Paul
McCartney not dying but there are those
there's a few of them like there's the
like I told you when you play revolution
number nine backwards yeah really sounds
like he's um saying turn me on Dedmon
turn me on denman okay and then it's
called the sergeant pepper inner groove
so there's like this little inner I
guess the inner groups League was small
the part in the middle of the record
that they just had this weird
five-second yeah thing with a bunch of
people saying something you don't know
what it is right um but if you do listen
you hear these little things that could
be clues and they deny it butter but how
that was so exciting and when you're 14
and you're listening to this and
breaking out the records and having your
friends to come over and listen to it
the first time I'm sure and you're
blowing people's minds man that's
awesome that's fun that is fun uh Jimmy
flam it has been an hour has it been
yeah you were worried I was worried was
this the family system it was a failure
it's never a failure it's never a
failure it's always the dark forest so
it's a different tree of the dork forest
and there's always a different angle of
what we were going to talk about so we
meandered around the Beatles I don't
know anything about the Beatles I know a
little bit about them I've you know more
I had only time in my head about is that
you asked me for a story behind song yep
I don't think I delivered that no no you
did not but here's the thing who cares
wikipedia you guys Rangers you know the
rules take care of each other out there
I hat my hat my hat they're dancing
around my hat I hat my hat my hat well
what do you think of that if it looks
like a mexican hat
sounds like a Mexican Hat dance it's
most likely a Mexican hackin so take off
your head and let's dance yay oh my god
we why don't we just call that as the
end of the show